each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay it's a great pleasure that
introduced out Austin um Todd got his
PhD at University of Wisconsin in 1996
he's currently a professor at the
University of Michigan in the electrical
engineering and computer science
department Todd's been doing lots of
really interesting work in architecture
for many years one of his great
contributions is the simple scalar
toolset which is widely used by the
entire architecture community Todd also
got a Maurice Wilkes award for
innovative contributions that computer
architecture in 2007 I think and today
is going to be talking about using
hardware to find security bugs that's
something of interest to many of us here
and please welcome time thank you thanks
pleasure to be here sigh things been
four years since I last visited yeah so
my background in computer architecture
most people think my background is a
computer architecture but really my
research is all about finding and fixing
bugs and faults so I work a lot in fault
tolerant systems i work in finding
software bugs and when you work in
software verification you can't help but
overlap heavily with security because a
lot of security bugs other a lot of
security vulnerabilities a result of
software bugs so today I want to talk
about some work that my two of my PhD
students have been working on a few
years ago Eric Larson who's now at
Seattle University worked on some work
on security vulnerability analysis of
programs I'll talk a little bit about
that and then my current graduate
students Joe grey house has been working
on developing techniques to scale the
performance of super heavyweight but
super powerful security vulnerability
analyses and I'll talk about that work
that's called testudo this is also joint
with other students and faculty as well
all right so I'm sure I don't have to
spend much time on this slide but you
know security vulnerabilities are a big
problem and I'm sure Microsoft everybody
knows this but i will show you one thing
yes i picked on Microsoft Windows but
that's not the only system that has bugs
in it to that people can
exploit Linux is more and more being
found to have lots of security bugs and
even simple devices you don't even need
an operating system simple devices like
RFIDs can be attacked as well so many
security vulnerabilities are the result
of bugs and software so if you can fix
these bugs you can eliminate the
vulnerability as opposed to trying to
detect the vulnerability and stop it
when it occurs if you fix the bug you
don't carry the payload of trying to
find that vulnerability and fix it at
runtime let's take a look at an example
of one security vulnerability bug and
classic one is the buffer overflow
attack so I've got this piece of code
here which it's a function that's got
some variable on the stack some local
variables as well and it reads some
input from external source and the
reason why this is a bug is because it
this particular function here doesn't
limit the amount it reads to 256 now
somebody comes and injects data into
this read input call here and it's less
than 200 integers it only partially
fills this buffer and everything's fine
the program intended as runs as it was
intended but if somebody reconstructs
the protocol for example and just
injects more data into it and even
violates the the purpose of the protocol
say injects more than 256 integers in
here what happens in this particular
attack is it overwrites the buffer then
the local variables above it and
eventually gets the return address the
nature of this particular attack is make
this data that you injected into the
program code and then try to figure out
the address to jump back into your own
injected data once you've done that
you've done what you fundamentally need
to do to implement this attack which is
redirect control from external data and
then when that's done you could take
over the machine there's a variety of
things you can do in this buffer to take
over the machine so how do you fix these
voters what's the classic approach
that's used most widely today to fix
these bugs that becomes
security vulnerabilities and it's as
follows write your application deploy
your application your customers let
people attack your customers customers
get upset complained to you debug the
attacks then fix the software and repeat
now this is effective but it has some
downsides one you get upset customers
when they get attacked and two you get
embarrassed software vendors because
some of these bugs can be you know
frankly can cause a lot of exposure so
what I want to talk about today is a
better way to attack these bugs and
that's through security vulnerability
analysis let's try and find the bugs
that hackers love before we release the
software but there's some challenges to
this but here's the basic approach
develop your program employs security
vulnerability analyses so there's a
variety of these there's many different
techniques I'm going to talk about one
today that I helped develop variety of
techniques employ this in the lab and
then debug whatever exposed
vulnerabilities you find continue to
develop your program and then iterate
around this cycle until you decide to
deploy the advantage of this approach is
that you'll find those bugs before you
put them out in the field but there's as
we're going to see there's a couple
problems with this approach well so it's
good for your customers because you get
more of those bugs out but the downside
is security vulnerability analysis tends
to be extremely heavy weight analyses
and when you're running very heavy
weight analyses that slowdown programs
by hundreds of times you tend to be
myopic and what you can test because you
simply don't have the resources to fully
test the program what does it mean to
fully test a program it means to cover
all of the feasible paths that the
program can possibly i execute and there
are billions of paths in non-trivial
programs so if this is slowing down your
program hundreds of times you probably
won't even be able to get through your
own test Suites let alone a test suite
that sort of example fuzz testing suite
think you could
coverage on pads in your program I'm
going to talk about today is I want to
talk about a technology called testudo
which pushes those analyses out into the
customer base and runs them on every
machine every time the program is run
using a data flow sampling technique
that can limit the amount of CPU and
memory resources it takes to do these
tests so the forward progress is made
but it's distributed across a large
customer base the great thing about this
approach is it works well with the
hacker bug economy which is as follows
hackers want bugs that occur on many
many machines so that when they devise
an attack they can grab as many ship
machines as possible in the same
scenario our analyses will run on many
many many machines so popular programs
will get the most amount of coverage
with the security vulnerability analysis
and my conjecture is that we using this
technology we can get ahead of the
attackers and find bugs before they do
yes are using allison machines that have
lately been honed and fiber offense
yeah well so like all technologies for
finding bugs you can use them both for
good and bad right so attackers could
use these technologies as well one
advantage that i have over the attackers
is that i have the advantage of my
entire customer base but an attacker
could definitely use this technology
also say to run these analyses on a
botnet for example good point and the
key point here is take the criminal out
of your design cycle I think this is a
really good approach to developing
software and one that we should all
strive for all right so here's I'm going
to talk about today I'm going to talk
about three technologies that that I've
worked on in my career first I'm going
to talk about metadata metadata is an
important aspect of security
vulnerability analysis it is information
that is attached to program data that
helps restore programmer intent in the
program as we run programmers we throw
away a lot of information we need to
read material eyes out that information
and metadata storage locations are where
we're going to store that then I'm going
to talk about one security vulnerability
analysis that I helped to develop a few
years ago called input bounds checking
which is going to try to determine if
the checks on data coming from external
sources are sufficient that you're
you're you're limiting the possibility
of dangerous memory accesses or changing
the control of your program without your
knowledge and then finally I'm going to
talk about my most recent work which is
the testudo project which is just
dynamic distributed debug how do we take
these super heavyweight analyses and
push them out into the field to try and
scale the performance and see more of
those feasible paths that are that our
customers are going to execute to try
and find more bugs all right so let's
take a look at metadata when you run a
program unfortunately the programmer
puts a lot of information at the source
level about what it is that he or she
wants to do but it really gets
unceremoniously discarded by the
compiler and the runtime system give you
an example here's a metadata strategy
that
I am I published many many years ago
called fat pointers which just tries to
read materialized intent behind how
programmers use pointers in a language
like C for example a pointer just
contains an address to a piece of
storage but it really there's a lot more
information there that would be useful
to store if we could for example what is
the variable that was intended to be
pointed to whether or not the variable
is live whether or not the variable has
some externally derived information in
it and whether or not that externally
drived information has been checked all
these kind of properties it's nice if we
have a place to store them so what
you'll see is in security vulnerability
analyses you'll see a need to declare
store and efficiently managed metadata
and so we'll see some of that later in
the talk when we look at the testudo
hardware implementation all right so
with the metadata we can start to do a
security vulnerability analysis and
there's many of these that are available
let me show you one that I worked on
called input bounds checking all right
so how do attackers look at programs
they basically look at them as big black
boxes with a bunch of knobs on them what
are the knobs the knobs of the inputs
that I can put into the program and for
the vast majority of attacks it is
simply finding the correct sequence of
turns of these knobs to cause the
program to access memory it didn't 10 or
change control in a way that it did not
originally intend that's the reason why
fuzz testing for example work so
effectively ad attacking programs
because with us says you're just turning
knobs randomly and looking at the
program crashes so so a great source of
bugs that we can find that can stop
security vulnerabilities is just fine
stuff that comes in from the outside
world these knobs that go to potentially
dangerous operations like memory
indirect pointer accesses or changes of
control in your program and finding out
if they haven't been properly bounded if
we can find those bugs we found a
significant number of bugs in that
kurz can exploit so the approach we use
with this input bounds vulnerability
analysis technique is we take a program
and at the low level it operates on you
know integer data and we combine it with
a symbolic copy of the same program that
does the same exact operations the ads
the subtract the loads and the stores
but instead of operating on concrete
data operates on symbolic data so we
take every variable say some variable X
has the value of 2a conakry value and we
clone it we we include metadata with X
which captures the range of X a symbolic
value of x this doesn't declare any
particular value of x but instead
declares a predicate which describes the
possible values of x okay so X can be
this value in the program and through
the metadata we know what possible
values it can be and we'll see by
propagating these symbolic values around
and pushing them through computation in
a symbolic fashion we can determine the
exact ranges and values of x whenever we
do a potentially dangerous operation now
if we also track oh I got a little hello
yeah if we also track the type
information as well which in some
languages we may have we may need to re
materialize this inside of our metadata
we can whenever we have a potentially
dangerous operation we can apply a proof
engine at the dereference or the change
in control and try to prove does this
predicate violate the constraints of
that type of that variable and you can
see if this is a see array has the value
index is 0 1 2 3 4 and this X has a
range of one to five we can see that
yeah there is a possibility that a bug
could occur here now what's really
powerful with this analysis is there's
no attack in this too this too is
perfectly valid but in the symbolic side
of the program we can see that attack
and that's the most powerful aspect of
this particular analyses it finds a tax
without an active exploit it's just
because the symbolic side of the
computation tracks the range over which
the values could exist and if there
doesn't exist if there does exist a
value that could provide an exploit it
will find it to find all of the exploits
for improperly bounded values we simply
have to have complete control flow
coverage of the program so we simply
have to hit all the feasible paths and
we will find all of the these particular
exploits I don't want to go to the
details of this analysis but i want to
show you by example how it works so you
can see how symbolic computation in the
background is a powerful way to find
next plate here's another program which
has a bug in we've got an array of five
elements we're going to get some input
we're going to check the constraint the
value of the input to see if it's within
bounds then increment the value that's
where the bug is because it no longer is
within the bounds of the array and then
we have a potentially buggy operation
and so we run the program and we get the
following values to which is legal
passes our test increment 2 3 no bug but
now look at the pair of the symbolic
computation which occurs in tandem with
the running program when we get the
value of x we see that the range of x is
any legal integer when we hit the
predicate we know from the direction of
the predicate here what the range of X
is X is now greater than equal to 0 or
less than or equal to 4 and we can
determine this by telling the direction
of the branch understanding the
predicate that's associated with the
branch and then using that predicate
intersecting that predicate with this
symbolic value to get the range then we
increment X and there's a calculus for
manipulating all of the symbolic values
so that when I increment X I simply
increment according to the calculus the
range the lower and upper bound of X so
now I know X is between one and five
then I go to this operation dereference
the ray then I run my proof engine I say
can this predicate produce a value which
violates the type of that array and yeah
it can't the value of five so no active
exploit I find my bug that's a very
powerful technique the way we
implemented it is we took GCC and we
instrumented the code such that as it
produced the individual operations it
also coupled down with a symbolic
version of the same of the same
low-level operation we then run a test
suite we look at our area reports and
then we go back fix the code and iterate
around this cycle so now we're doing
that security vulnerability analysis to
try and get rid of our bugs and in the
world of students security vulnerability
analysis when you read papers in that
domain every once in a while you see a
paper that actually finds a really good
bug and our paper found what I consider
to super high quality bugs we found two
bugs in openssh that were fixed almost
immediately one was a bug one was a
buffer overflow attack the other wasn't
an attack that occurred that where you
could use integer overflow to attack the
system but here's the downside of the
snails yes fine bugs did you eat if you
actually each the predicate that
here another branch to be switched
example if you have to go to a separate
path when the array check out right
firstly near the input that mm-hmm stir
that takes that path yes and then comes
to the Ranger yes today this technique
might not
because you know JT labels
like I can combine my predicates at the
moment so I don't quite understand your
point I think he's saying that you only
find bugs on branches that were followed
during the program execution of analyzed
yes that's driven by the concrete guys
correct correct but let's say I cover
all my feasible paths will I find all
the books
so I you know good point so that's the
challenge here is finding all the fees
there exponentially many
there are many paths I mean I don't know
how many feasible nobody's nobody can I
mean we don't know how many feasible Paz
room yeah they're exponential with the
depth of the control graph there's a lot
so I need a highly scalable technique to
implement this analysis but what is
their competition practice i'll get to
some that yes very familiar with it
tastes a check type state checking yeah
it's grabbing me a six it's a static
pilot approves program correctly yep yep
yeah I'm familiar with that work and
like the prefix work a variety of
techniques right and those techniques
are very similar to this right the
difference is is that I'm analyzing has
their run in the program and those
techniques are are essentially
symbolically running the program ya know
there's static route so they can destroy
I regret but they have to do some level
of symbolic computation to figure out
what pads are possible okay
you're captain sensible
well if the path and sensitive they're
going to tons a positive of 12 also
false positives the false positive
program that is a type state safe and
they rejected it possibly unsafe
okay so we can talk more about that but
general static techniques cannot
complete a non-trivial program will you
give me that one no I'll give you that
little bit I can't even write exam
dynamic can't either so what I'm talking
about today is a scalable dynamic
technique that can go further than any
past dynamic and with static techniques
we can do the same thing as well well
maybe we can someday meet in the middle
and find all the feasible paths so good
comments thank you very much yes so r is
the window main you use
your static analysis
yeah primarily intervals although we use
a different style of analysis for
Strings
so the downside of this approach is it's
really slow these are some programs
these are their their original runtimes
their runtimes with full instrumentation
and this is how many times slower they
run with that instrumentation load on
them and you know in the best case about
forty three percent slower in the worst
case about two hundred percent or two
hundred times slower so significant
payload in the background there to do
that symbolic computation so it really
limits the number of paths that you can
that you can analyze when your programs
running hundreds of times slower so the
point of this is the cell analysis is
very effective but it's extremely
expensive what I want is an analysis
that I can hit all of my feasible pads
on so now let's take a look at the work
they've been doing recently which yes
yes so if it's so expensive
is but is it still a lot cheaper than
doing a full static analysis
find all possible
well so I'm unaware of a full static
analysis that finds all possible paths
that doesn't do enough abstraction that
you have to either sort of have a lot of
false positives or don't find certain
kind of bugs so and I'm unaware of any
dynamic analysis that can hit all the
feasible paths because it's so expensive
to do that kind of analysis so what I'm
going for is in the middle dynamic
analysis that scales too many many
machines so i can hit more feasible
paths than anyone has in the past I'm
just elated is just the cost of immune
to symbolically I mean expression not be
at the very end of the talk I'm going to
talk about some very new work that I've
been working on which is to try and take
the set and the probabilities of
feasible paths and help static analysis
drive better with that knowledge because
I think ultimately the best solution is
going to be partially dynamic to find
out what customers do and provide a lot
of predicate information about feasible
paths and then use that in the static
domain to try and find paths that are
almost impossible to expose without
really clever inputs yes yeah I guess I
guess one thing is unclear is the so if
you run so static analysis and you know
and you don't want to reject every
program right you so you make some
compromises says you're not going to
find everybody but you're going to find
somebody right and you're going to find
some books and I guess one question that
comes to mind is how much overlap I mean
how many of the things that you found
here would have been found by a
reasonable static analysis writer like
prefix
maybe not just that one but there are
these abstract interpretation based
approaches worth it yeah I I don't know
the answer that question we actually
tried to answer that for Erik Larsen
thesis which was back in about two
thousand five and he tried to gather a
lot of tools to do this sort of
overlapped coverage analysis at the
point in the end you know these tools
tend to be real fragile and it takes a
lot of deep knowledge to get different
codes running
I think today with you know tools like
Oh Verity and such we could probably do
a better job although today and I'm
source yes Oh type state actually does
all those things you say it can't be
done but it only does it on speaking
clean clean language it's like none of
the one who all right re are you how
pervasive programming language grungy
code stuff can you can well today I do
the analyses at the instruction so I'm
really looking at the lowest level of
the machine I'm looking how information
flows at that lovely I light fighter
yeah okay you can do this analysis at
higher and higher levels and it would be
more as you as you have more type
information you have to check less
because the language itself provides you
guarantees unless the language has bugs
in it in which case you don't have those
games like see you do have to preserve
type information like they were a size
and like that right so the language does
have to provide enough information
so yeah well he's doing binaries there's
no like honey well that's how curious
about heaven if you're doing its to
invent I'm Barney or so if we have like
debug information and we have
instrumentation in the malic and fries
we can read material eyes most of the
type of marriage some of the type
information we generate on demand based
on how you access
yes that's the position this relatives
web das network
seems cycads like very like I don't know
if I games for dates at arts having
similar direction and it seems like
maybe a fun distinction is the actual
texts that are being put in
discussions deserve it we are using all
these techniques they are running 100
machines as we speak in the stage
present a few windows etc where we had
in addition to that we address the other
heart problem which is test generation
how do you get basically so that's why
not only we generate this constraint we
also we generate new test also another
thing here is that you can have false
alarms because your symbolic execution
are very large program could basically
you could have your Ain array balance or
the constraint soldier give you oh they
could be a performer pro here but
actually it may not be so in addition
you generate the test and you run the
program and only then if you find a bug
then you basically tell the developer
because otherwise you have Co false
alarms there's a few cases of hosting
these techniques quite effectively and
we haven't way also to extend them in
combining this test generation so it's
really exactly I mean it's very release
so this this work was done in 2002 just
to put it in context all right I think
I'm one of the earliest people to do
this come colic style execution I only
presented here just to sort of put
context around the work that I'm doing
but I know I know people have gone way
past this stuff I'm sure people here
identify use as you gonna sure miss you
should get you foresee they have various
ways to extend this work I mean one is
to do just generation giving it throws
lab yep you exert its like what about in
the field that's we are not doing so so
we have let's see let's see my proposal
for going to the field okay and I
definitely i know i'm meeting with a
number of you out there i'm looking
forward to hear more about what's going
on and that's why I'm here I want you
guys to tell me what's crap about this
let's good as I knew that I would get
that here alright so testudo the
approach is it's different than
traditional heavyweight analysis
techniques where we're going to take a
program we're going to send into our
instrumentation framework it's something
that's fully instrumented send it into
the in-house server we're going to run
those analyses it's going to take quite
a while we'll find some bugs and we'll
fix those bugs with testudo we're going
to take a program we're going to
instrument it we're going to deploy it
to all the customers and we're going to
use a control system to limit the amount
of analysis that occurs to a set amount
of CPU and memory overhead so we have to
devise an analysis that we can decompose
sufficiently that we can throw away
information but guarantee forward
progress over time but also limit the
amount of overheads and I'll show you
that for this particular input bounds
analysis over time running a virtually
full speed customers will run into bugs
the approach we've taken today is
completely uncoordinated completely
random if people stumble over bugs they
have the option of reporting them back
and then we can push out updates fix the
bugs and all the customer base
and customers of course are never happy
but hopefully using this technique their
frustration will starts subsiding so
let's take a look at this I want to
present another piece of code that I'm
going to analyze its going to read some
external input and then just do some
computation but this time I'm going to
present it as a data flow and the reason
I'm going to do that is because the way
we're going to optimize these analyses
is by recognizing that the analyses vast
majority of security vulnerability
analyses are tracking data as it flows
through your program and by sampling
paths on data flows we can make forward
progress while limiting amount of work
we do so I read some data 2x i compute a
value of y i compute the value of a z y
plus ok so note this was my external
input data these are all the particular
operations I check but know if I just
follow one of these paths from the start
to the end and ignore everything else I
actually make forward progress on my
analysis and that's the decomposition
mechanism i'm going to use i'm going to
manage my metadata in a way where I
throw away information if I have too
much load on the system and I make
forward progress for at least one path
every once in a while limiting CPU and
memory overheads so that users don't
complain about our analysis and then
push that as widely as possible and then
we're going to see how many machines I
need to implement that so for example
doing a sample data flow analysis you
know I can if I analyze X and skip why
an a I can no longer analyze Z because i
have no metadata I can't analyze Z and
when I get to this see I can't analyze
that metadata if I choose to do so the
asterisks are showing me how far I got I
can run this again i get if i get the
same input to the same piece of code I
hit the state of flow again this time I
go down this path I analyze that a I
analyze the Z decide not to analyze why
decide not to analyze this see and then
in a third pass I do it again now
because I'm uncoordinated with this
initial approach
I can get a lot of overlap here I may
analyze things a lot of times over and
over again but over time I should get
very good coverage on the paths that are
being executed
how do i limit the cost of storage well
I only need one metadata value in the
system to make forward progress on
analysis one single metadata value so
for example if I have a structure which
I call the sample cash which is tracking
one particular variable in the system if
I'm tracking nothing here if I track x I
can pass I can then overwrite that with
the metadata of why I no longer have
this metadata but I did analyze this
note here now I've metadata here I
decide not to analyze a I replace the
metadata y with Z and now I have
metadata here and now I can't analyze
why because I no longer have metadata
for why I can't analyze the I no longer
have meditated for X but with a single
location I've done one path right
because I just need one location to hit
each one of these paths now if I build
them this sample cash and I randomly
replace in it and not deterministically
replace in it then with a population of
users i can get coverage on all of the
data paths but it's got to be random
select different things every time and
non deterministic so that if to users
run the program with the same inputs
they don't select the same paths if I
have more than one entry I'll get better
coverage on these because I can store
more paths at the same time each entry
will allow me to track one path at a
time but if I get too much load on the
system I can always choose to invalidate
entries out of my metadata cash to
reduce the amount of workload that I
have doing analysis so I have a
mechanism to throw stuff away and see
less work until I get to one entry and
I'll keep that one entry around just to
make sure that I make forward progress
on my analyses yes
don't attack the whole path to know
whether you seem a cozy before well I
know if I have tracked it let's say I
hold Y here I know that I have if i have
only one made of data value i know that
i've reached on a path from some input
that i declared is interesting to this
particular value and as I see why
propagate to other values I can randomly
choose whether or not to take those new
values or hold on to the value of y but
there's only one way to reach the line
that's true and that's another data flow
and as I see that other data flow I can
get coverage on that as well i guess but
i confuse without is easier keep a
single value there that seems you have
to keep some notion whether your current
path looking for it and that's not as
larger than like a single 30
no I don't have any information about
I'm just randomly selecting where to go
to next and you know what this becomes
is this classic statistical problem
called the coupon collectors problem
with no state but randomly selecting
where to go to next in a graph I always
get to all the leaf nodes eventually
it's not very efficient and the approach
i don't i have here isn't particularly
efficient and my students are working on
better techniques random algorithms that
can do a better job of covering this but
i just want to make the point today one
data value I can make coverage
alright so the quote the point here is
individual analyses are very cheap I'm
going to scale performance on many runs
with many customer machines and I'm
going to increase the size of this cash
to cover more flows at the same time and
that cash by invalidating that cash is a
powerful mechanism to reduce the amount
of analysis that I have and to reduce
the cost of analysis on any individual
now there's two implementations that
tests to do there's the published one
which is a hardware implementation it
was in micro 08 and then we just we're
publishing a paper next year on the
software version i'm going to talk a
little bit about the software only
version but first I just want to present
the the hardware approach
just walking down the pipeline showing
you what I need to implement technology
first I need metadata for register
values anything that lives in a register
I want to attach metadata to and we
don't sample the data on registers we
just every registered gets its own
metadata and what this information is is
just a pointer to kernel memory that
tells us what where the actual metadata
is stored because we don't really
presuppose what the metadata is in the
system we just track whether any
particular data value heads metadata and
what the pointer is to that in the
execute stage we need to have the
ability to propagate metadata and to
remember how that was propagated so if
we get a variable a added to why we need
to be able to produce the metadata for
the result now sometimes it is very
simple for example if you're doing taint
analysis if there's one input that's
tainted the output is tainted and you're
done you're doing something like
symbolic analysis you've got to go and
compute what's the calculus of a plus y
on this metadata and what's my new
metadata and we'll see later in the
pipeline we have a place where we can
initiate a kernel call to to actually
compute that data so we don't really
presuppose what that analysis is give
you this at the instruction level right
so you know you don't necessarily have a
connection between a register value and
I'm variable right so don't you have to
look up the
the debug information every time yes so
that so yes so for example when metadata
materializes is where we'll get most
that information so when we take the
address of something or when we create
some new piece of storage what that's
where we'll get the majority that
metadata and then the way as metadata
mixes within instructions we've got
these colonel routines that will decide
how to put together and I'll advise you
to look at this usenix security paper
and you can see there's a big table that
shows for every instruction what that
come places
in the mem stage we have a sample cache
which is simply a hardware cash that
holds metadata pointers so and their
associated with a particular address
physical address so if there's some
metadata attached to a particular memory
address and we do a load or a store that
will materialize in the registers and
this sample cash is small it's typically
on the order of 128 or 256 entries and
it's randomly replaced so we select the
entry randomly and non deterministically
so when we're manipulating this we gotta
we have to have some source of true
random information in the system so that
when we have separate runs on separate
machines we don't see the same updates
that cash so you could good coverage on
the data flows
fortunately in many hardware today
there's excellent sources of random
information for example Intel processors
many of them have the ability to turn
thermal noise into random numbers and
those are very useful in this this
approach and then finally at the end of
the pipeline when we retire the
instruction the instruction may have
done something that is beyond the scope
of what the pipeline can do so we have
this policy map which basically allows
us to say for example if you have two
pieces of metadata on this OP code then
I want a colonel in interrupt that goes
to this address and allows you to
emulate more complex manipulation of
metadata as instructions arrive
software support for testudo is first we
have an OS level controller which is
going to non deterministic ly limit new
analyses and fan out by watching the
overheads in the system if if the
overheads are low we're going to try
increase flow selection so when we see
new data created we're going to start
following it and we're going to preserve
fan out so when we see new values coming
out of a particular value we create new
metadata for when the threshold gets too
high we're going to decrease flow
selection it's less likely that a new
flow will get a net analyzed and we're
going to reduce family by invalidating
entries of the sample cash until we get
to the point where we only have one data
flow and we preserve that one data flow
even to the point of violating the
constraints on CPU and memory overhead
and then once that's gone well wait till
we get back below that max load and go
back into deciding whether to increase
or reduce the flow in addition there's
special instructions in the architecture
that let us mark things that should have
metadata initially and in our
implementation those are in the device
drivers when stuff comes from network or
from keyboard or from external other
external sources it gets marked all
right quickly how do we do analysis of
this so we took a vertex simox and we
ran a bunch of programs that had some
exploits that we could create in them
and we ran them on our simulator the
problem with our simulator tends to be
slow and we wanted to get coverage over
many many many thousands of runs so what
we did is we wrote out as we executed
these experiments the data flows that we
saw just the data flows themselves and
then brought them into a Monte Carlo
simulator which would implement many
different analyses of those particular
data flows for the sample cash so one
particular run produces a payload of
data flows that we then do thousands and
thousands of analyses in this Monte
Carlo simulator for the sample cash to
see how we get coverage over time how
many runs do I need for some programs I
don't need a lot of runs to give full
coverage on the data flows that I saw
the order of hundreds of more machines
and that with a larger sample cash 64
instead of 32 even less because I can
track more data flows at a time for
other programs I need more like SQL
injection had I need as many as
seventeen thousand runs to fully cover
the data flows that I saw in the
original run of the program this number
right here is a ninety-five percent
confidence that you've covered all of
the data flow paths that you saw in the
original run of the program so if you
run your experiment you've got a
ninety-five percent probability of
seeing this is the case it has to do
with the depth of the data flows and a
bushiness of the data flows and the size
of the sample cash and the amount of
analysis that you have to the payload of
analysis so if you have unlimited
analysis and a huge sample cash you can
get very good coverage but as you start
to tighten the amount of stuff you can
look at tighten the amount of overheads
that you can tolerate you need more and
more runs yes yeah thank es su run
PDF that we just ran one execution of
the program with one export so this is
how many times to get coverage on that
particular run but they're put the other
has many many many many runs right so I
want to cover many many many paths so
this is trying to figure out what the
explosion factor is exactly ok so the
leverage that I'm going to get in this
system is you know for example apache
web server started 570,000 five seconds
so if i can put this technology into a
widely used program over time i'm going
to get a huge amount of leverage and
over time i'm going to work to try and
make this even more efficient cg you
have a false-positive problem right not
a very large pulse house okay but but i
think india using the end the question
becomes so you have hundreds of
thousands of this david flowing in honey
prior cuts how do you know that
something is really a good bug to go
after versus the other 100 million a
year that's a good not so yeah so one
thing we have is we have excellent
information about how likely the path
you're on is which is a very powerful
piece of memory which gives us a
priority
so if one of the fundamental assumptions
here seems to be that control paths
don't don't change before the exploit
would happen whereas up and a lot of
bulbs are we've got IE 9 and 0 it still
let's go for support in it and so it
turns out that nodes used go for in 15
years and so I'm going to come up with
some bug in the way that gopher parse is
something right and so in that case just
by sending gopher colon slash slash or
whatever it is right the attacker has
already taken you off any path that any
non-adversarial users actually thank you
yeah excellent excellent point so this
really only gives you good coverage on
paths that customers run or on widely
exploited bugs so you see actually see
get coverage on the bugs the attacks
themselves but I got a foot in that game
as well because I get excellent
information about what customers do and
I can use that information with static
analysis to figure out feasible paths
that customers don't do and I think
ultimately I can I can leverage the
information that I can gather in the
field to really understand what are the
possible paths that are not executed
which I think are another great source
of bugs as you point out and then once
you then you've covered all the paths
right what door should follow up on
Stewarts are there questions I've never
I mean going to say that this is perhaps
most suitable for its part you know for
for finding functionality box then
vulnerabilities
as you said we will look at things that
nobody else in there like right mind
would sort of general idit do you think
its vulnerability so it's a really
functionality bugs that this is possible
I guess I don't see the distinction
what's the distinction revolt ability
and I don't I don't understand the
terminology but I do understand that
that this technology is going to be
limited to has that hit execute baby
subsidiary up but that's just a little
sticker but super duper symbolic asked
for fire and so it gives you exactly how
the users enlarge are using the specific
thing and a lot of information that you
can leverage out that but the match with
security with security may not be the
killer app for that machinery because
many security vulnerabilities are you
exotica dead code thing that never never
never executed but still being shipped
all kind of reasons and they have a
various and they are very specific to
that and hitting those in the wild is it
actually can be rare in some cases and I
was going to ask you do you have
evidence that we need for instant you
know and study looking at a thousand
goon abilities for instance and how many
of them were in a frequently Traverse
path versus almost dead code for
instance i mean i do not know i don't
know what that either and i think that's
an excellent question another
perspective is what you're catching is
what we've already have encapsulated
which then existing technology would
actually have well that that's true of
your test if your test coverage is equal
to your customer coverage yes hey look
this absolutely big this is how you
build a test suite of thanks I'm good
over for a person in that Microsoft we
have this huge problem app compact as we
call it up application compatibility etc
there are so many unions of parameters
that defines basically hardware space
and the widgets triste whatever you name
it we have I mean it's very hard test
you know exactly what's gonna and so
this actually I mean suppose you guys
could answer this question right what
how many bugs do you fix on popular
parts of the code and how many bugs you
fix in the crafty coat you ought to have
those stats but we have a great tool now
its goal blossom and so but that's
another story you don't hear about that
huh well we did i'm sitting ocular code
are pardoned right but what you say is
we know where the bugs in the popular
culture are so it's very easy to fix
well it's not easy to fix those but
there's a long queue of those to get so
all of the new bugs all the new bugs are
seeing are in the crafty code no I'm
seeing some knows some yeses well part
of effectiveness
functionality bugs and abilities
vulnerabilities allows adversaries
security laws
most usually running code as you
functionality but could be something as
simple as there's a misspelling in this
form it's a bad customer impact as it
makes us look like idiots but you know
it's not going to let an episode
so I think I mean so it's important to
understand a little bit about Watson so
Watson basically is the online crash
analysis so whenever something crashes
it will send back the thing Microsoft if
you say yes okay so what you see there
is you see inputs that are going to
actually caused the crash so you're
seeing things that aren't the ones that
caused the crash that could and we're
seeing the ones that really did I think
what you see from this from the ones
that actually caused it to crash you see
a distribution and so we see that we can
see the numbers just like you'll see the
numbers right so this one seems to occur
long occurs often um and that allows us
to prioritize but but given that we have
real crashing things and we know how
frequent they happen we can't fix all so
we're already a world where here's you
know here's we have 10,000 and here's
the top 100 that we're going to fix I
guess my question is if we have this
additional information to feed in its
into that pool I see I see your point
yeah really what it held its an
interesting thing to think about it's a
very good piece
but he's got all the information about
you know if he's doing some bog analysis
that he'll see it puts that you never
saw in practice it would still positive
maybe wanting to think about the case of
a destination somebody is not coming
from if you think of the betta day as
like billions of all formulas I think
that's streaming them back to the
mothership over time you can build a big
symbolic you know sketch like suffer
exactly and they'll help you awesome i'm
definitely moving towards okay good
thank you very much excellent feed bags
that's why I'm here all right how much
does it cost the hardware for this isn't
that expensive so we looked at the cost
of 256 to 1k cash is on relative to the
size of a AMD phenom or a ultrasparc
doesn't really hit cycle time that much
and fairly low in terms of percentage
and so I was in I was at Intel Israel
two weeks ago telling about this
technology you know Intel all the action
is in Israel that's how they do the
process and and you know it's trying to
push this technology and somebody pulled
me aside and said you know Ruth secret
building this
for software based transaction so
there may be there may be some synergies
between that and this it will allow
technologies like this
pretty excited about that pasta
let me tell you a little bit about
future work on this
just that just recently got a paper into
cgo 11 which is a hundred percent
software implementations one of the
challenges of seeing how well this works
is you got to really roll it out and see
how well it works it's hard to do with
just mighty Carl analysis so what we
built is a lamp stack that uses this
technology we've got linux OS we're
connected into the lamp stack through
analysis of where drivers that can mark
data and then this runs on top of a xen
hypervisor which has a sample cash
implemented with shadow page so i just
use a virtual memory system attract
might Nita and it's a little more
cumbersome because I have to throw away
whole pages of data when I want to throw
away analysis or pare down a page to a
single value if it's my last one my load
controller would decide when to throw
away data when not to initiate new
analyses to control my loads and then
when I want to do analyses I shift over
to a qemu demand-driven analysis
actually going to do interpretation
under the colonel to figure out how to
propagate that information through
registration the downside of this it's
we're gonna it's about quite a bit more
expensive and I'm going to need more
runs to do the same amount of coverage
the advantage is eventually I'll be able
to deploy this another thing that I'm
very interested in engaging on and I'm
currently starting to work on this is
using the technology that we can harvest
in the field to find unlikely feasible
paths using static analysis because I
think I can gain a lot of very good
information about how the program is
used and a lot of symbolic information
to help you find feasible paths in the
program and then generally what I need
to implement this technology and
generally what you need to implement a
variety of vulnerability analysis is you
need efficient fine-grained memory
protection what we really need is to
abandon pages of 4k and I want to be
able to mark bytes as code and data and
I want an efficient mechanism so my
student Joe greet house is the end of
his thesis is really
looking on coming up with efficient fine
grain memory protection techniques and
there's just a variety of things you can
implement you can do garbage collection
you can do software-based transactional
memory you can do security analysis you
can do security attack prevention
varieties of things so I think there's a
huge benefit to try and revisit the
virtual memory protection system and try
and make it more fine-grained yes yes
there was a reason Intel workshop where
the discussion was around whether Intel
should support some kind of mechanisms
like this and it was sort of more broad
as its lifeguards work and but the
bottom line is ya ne ne mu Omega
interaction you can have to give until
reasons to do this would be great I mean
I think that you know the fact of a
spots of the workshop so basically some
believe internally that you know they
need to be looking instruction but it's
been a hard sell I mean you know this is
the same story was true 15 years ago
right hand you know and they've heard it
I mean it's not like it's they don't
know that my great memory protection
mechanisms are going to give you a lot
of to give some service and software but
i think the economic argument around how
it helps customers is still not there so
they're ready yet it is true that all
the benefits for their 15 years ago
this is unfair and exaggerated will make
the point they no longer many things but
open but given that they still asking
the question whose gonna buy us I mean
we found of no I understand and in fact
that the discussion at this workshop was
a for you know could we could we create
a skew of a processor that we sold for
more money and only target of developers
another exam because developers want to
really want this and your average
customer doesn't see the value so how
much more would it put it developer pay
for with Microsoft Paint you know you're
here he's not the Microsoft employee my
name is I know who I every 0 people
nothing but just kidding recorded I
don't I don't I don't so when I
presented this in Microsoft they they
they felt uncomfortable like I don't
think we'd put a security something to
help find security bugs in our posture
because that would just imply that we
have a lot of security bugs on the
platforms that we use our processors in
which seems like a very seems like an
odd thing to say but from a marketing
standpoint you know that that might you
know it might people my fear a system
that has to fix bugs right so you know
my my idea is you should you should just
make it you should what you should do is
you should say that you know this has
branded with you know extra security
extra safety technologies if you could
show a benefit to an individual customer
that's really good and they put up put
it in and make a snake and market with
it but what you're talking about our
developer tools it makes the software
better but but it's only indirect but
don't like being my usual anymore for my
processor I don't get the benefit is
here's one here's the way you get the
benefit the customer we've got great
information on the likelihood of the
path the plug is the potential bug and
what you do is if the likelihood drops
below a certain level you just you say
hey here's a fifty dollar off coupon if
you hit send your your next Microsoft
ride
and then it becomes then it becomes a
valuable tickets so you say maybe these
people folks ponies bad luck like our
school not one digit the dollars go for
it again is that this on the knife
between benign user side like us and
we'll be looking for problem with the
attackers they're just one right the
attacker isn't the isn't the hive right
there just one person in I so their
probability of finding these are very
very so what got was borderline Joe
we're talking about the software patient
today when you can get down to really
act on Zen and are really fast so I'm
not going to go into details on this yet
but it's about three times as many runs
to reach the same level of coverage for
me is someone running on top of this do
I see 2x slow down and 5x slow down all
of our experiments are limited to five
percent memory and five percent sub a
great thank you so it's it's just
shaving
okay sue over the glass Donna no 7 57
years of sin basically decline and these
low-level memory of types of
vulnerabilities and increase in
vulnerabilities like Wells a sequential
process 50-point have you those browser
things now and so on and so forth and
the historical keeps evolving so what do
you thoughts on applying techniques that
are absolutely this maiden of the olefin
where someone else to those more
semantic from disabled so anywhere so I
think that this work is valuable
anywhere we have data flow you have
invariance that you can either infer or
exist in my case they exist but maybe
you can infer those invariants and
there's a lot of work in that domain and
and overheads are a concern then I think
these kind of sampling techniques can
work at anything
and it's a dynamic analysis
actually honest and this in the I was
doing this in the best place for the
distributes case where we're trying to
improve
the state of a web application in space
users traversal algorithm and it is the
same story and actually in particular
the users have an exact distribution
they will go to the Google homepage they
will go to Gmail home page they're not
going to explore the Preferences it is
the same sir
so can you say a little bit about the
relationship between my memories we had
light guards and this kind of stuff hits
his target now for security specifically
but just for instrumentation and fern
p.m. circle turn in a general way so I
guess the question is could you
implement bunch of what you're talking
about with the same mechanism but not a
hundred percent familiar with lifeguards
okay what is give me a justice to the
hell the high-level take away its it
it's a it's a hardware channel that
allows information about things that are
happening instructions things like what
address is being accessed etcetera to be
sent over to a separate core on that on
the multi-core and handled they're
essentially so it's you know it's a
high-bandwidth way to collect data in
the running processor so that would be a
good mechanism to implement this kind of
analysis right so and it's in in a sense
all those policy-map calls could go over
to another
ya could go over to another I think
okay and then lastly just really
interested in adapting this another and
their analysis techniques the core of
the testudo work is not really security
we've applied it to security but it's
really data flow analysis and currently
Joe my students is applying this to
finding race bugs in parallel programs
which is another very good day that's
super
so let's bring this full circles you see
started by talking about impulse tests
and chemistry meeting this back in the
center of the field and then you know we
talk about data centers it's essentially
bringing much of that tag in how sakura
so what are you thoughts on you know
avoir putting this into data center what
a grade of c c from from that it's even
more ideal right because you have lots
of systems running many times your
software and in addition you it's in
your own domain so that you have more
ability to provide information that's
necessary to improve the analysis reduce
the cost of analysis like for example I
can provide a lot of type information a
lot of invariants that I've collected
over time that I wouldn't push out to a
customer because that information might
be privileged or important I don't want
to release that intellectual property
now I now since this local I can do even
better so I see this in the data center
is being an even more powerful
all right so it's conclude you want to
beat the hackers find the bugs they love
and fix them before they do get rid of
those zero-day exploits talked about
three technologies metadata restores
programmers intent and we need a
mechanism to manage this efficiently
input bounds checking as an example of a
security vulnerability analysis that
finds those bugs before you release
software the advantage of this
particular technology is it finds
exploits without an active attack the
problem with these technologies are too
expensive they really slow down programs
so testudo is a technology that can roll
these roll these analyses out into the
field and use the customer base is a
massively parallel system to find these
bugs in an uncoordinated random way so
thank you very much by the way I want to
tell you what a test udo is this is a
test udo it's a Roman legion formation
where they take you to their shields and
lock them together to form one single
protection for the entire mass so that's
why we called it tested oh yeah of
course this this is a yeah these are
your device drivers and your and your
hypervisor which is unprotected thank
you very much just one question um so
you you're doing it alone at you know
buffer overflows certain array out of
bounds errors but but you sector 3 is
actually a major source of attack in
fact it's one it seems will Campbell I
mean even if you completely remove all
the buffer overflows you still have a
lot of Holland village
I mean that would fit great into this
can you can you do anything that's a
data flow analysis right the the
metadata I need is whether storage is
like some capability associated with the
birds right so yeah okay let's say I did
it like like we did it when i worked on
safety years ago we generated
capabilities for all heap storage we
attached to the pointers and we
propagated those capabilities and those
capabilities were destroyed when the
data was free this is data flow analysis
but I could sample in the system to try
and find where when I dereference is
that particular capability that is that
mark still existing that would fit into
this style than else